thousands on the streets of the Mexican
capital
it's one of the largest pro-democracy
demonstrations in years
today we all come together because we
want to defend democracy
protests against a proposed change to
the country's electoral system took
place in more than a dozen Mexican
cities critics say the changes threaten
the independence of Mexico's national
electoral Institute or INE which
oversees Federal elections
many people are worried about the path
our democracy is taking we are worried
if our country is uh going to end up as
other countries like Venezuela
the protests in Mexico City was the
largest to date against the Electoral
reforms the changes being proposed by
Mexico's president are part of a broad
set of reforms that Encompass everything
from the implementation of electronic
voting machines to a reduction in the
number of seats in Mexico's Congress
critics however say that under the
surface the proposed reforms have the
potential to undermine Democratic
institutions in Mexico
for his part president Andres Manuel
Lopez obrador says his reform is aimed
at reducing election costs and
increasing transparency and says the
protests are fueled by his political
opponents
people should not be fooled they should
know that this March is a demonstration
against our government because of our
policies
while some warn the proposed reform puts
too much power in the hands of federal
government constitutional experts say
the country would benefit from certain
changes so long as the plans are
discussed openly within Mexico's
Congress
as long as the reform is debated in
legislative space with participation
from the public the Integrity of the
Indian national electoral Institute is
not in danger in fact the Ina has been
modified in the past just as life in
Mexico has also been modified over time
though presidential elections in Mexico
are still two years away political
observers say the latest demonstrations
are evidence of growing political
polarization with many in the country
seeing the next elections as a battle
over the future of Mexican democracy
[Music]
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Mexico City